this is a production of Cornell
University
hi it's been great being here so far is
a lot of fun being in a plant biology
department I've been in earth science
departments my whole career and it's
been very nice talking to people many
actual botanists but even though there's
a lot of plant biology in this room I
think it's important to explain why I'm
a plant biologist and what I think of my
plants because it very well may be
different from the way a lot a lot of
people think about plants for me the the
real draw for plants primarily is the
fact that they have cell walls and a lot
awful lot falls out of that as far as
what you can do with them as fossils
this is a fossil that's 300 million
years old the snails are just shells the
plant in between is a plant we have all
this anatomy it's all there and given
that plants are largely visible
creatures involved in conducting water
and so on we can actually say a lot
about how this thing function based upon
having that that's a anatomy present the
original cell walls are preserves that
biochemistry is there so we can talk
about the evolution different
biochemical cell wall compounds and so
on and also kind of perhaps less
immediately but also very importantly
because the F cell walls is no cell
migration so their development is much
simpler than what you'd expect to see in
an animal with gastrulation and so on
and look at the final adult morphology
and say something about how it got there
in a much more direct way then then you
could with an animal and so on on top of
that plants are all trying to make their
living the same way and nearly all
aspects of land plant form has evolved
multiple times convergently based upon
that so we have lots of independent
experiments looking at the evolution of
different structures so if we look at
this phylogeny of living vascular plants
here blue needs to make it back to
Devonian and so on it looks like if you
know what these guys are that it looks
like there's a lot of morphological
continuity there as far as roots and
leaves and so on but the common
ancestors of these lineages are very
small and simple and most of what it
looks like these things might share has
actually evolved independently and
that's something we can directly assess
from the foster record where all these
guys have leaves they look kind of funny
but we look at slightly older members of
those lineages and they were going to
see nothing but these things slightly
older there won't be leaves at all so we
can actually trace the evolution of
these things and compare multiple
evolutions have very similar structures
and finally something that it's taken me
many years to really fully appreciate
that animals are cute right or they're
scary whatever but plants through the
carbon cycle they're all the biomass
they are the hydrologic cycle and all
the water in the atmosphere pleasure
climate and so the evolution of these
guys and the evolution their physiology
really is the evolution of the Earth's
surface in a very direct way and there's
been a whole lot of turnover through
time in what those plants are like and
that turnover matters right there's a
lot of focus on this kind of turnover
down there with the animals but they're
really kind of passive recipients of a
world that these guys are making for
them now my heart of hearts lies down
here and the Paleozoic and all the crazy
beasts that are down there today I'm
gonna focus on on these guys the
flowering plants now I am NOT an
angiosperm person they scare me
there are far far far too many of them
I'm not an angiosperm person but I think
that has some utility to looking from
the outside in towards the angiosperms
it can give you some perspective on what
it is that they're doing differently
that it's harder to see from the inside
and then hopefully if I have enough time
understanding what's going on here also
reflects back on what's going on back
there okay so my primary kind of entry
into the fossil record has always been
leaves initially I was interested in
leaf development and how we can use the
nation patterns to say something about
where growth is occurring within these
leaf structures how laminate surface of
all multiple times and so on I was doing
that from in my thesis and so on since
then and we can use venetian patterns to
say something about sequential
appearances of morphology indicating
sequential appearances of different
developmental modes showing up in
multiple independent lineages here over
time I got more interested in the fact
that these things are not just passive
records of development they also matter
for how this thing is functioning
physiologically they're conducting the
water and water matters if you're a
plant so I got more interest in the
physiology and as I did I was amused by
this a basic little lie in the way I've
always presented this all right this
might as well been from my thesis
depends here I'm indicating about how
ferns me very closely converged upon the
nation patterns seen in angiosperms but
there's a lie and the way I presented
that which is that they're not presented
at the same
scale if they were they would look like
that there's a lot more veins in the
flight line and this actually is going
to end up mattering quite a bit for how
these things can function so if you're a
plant you're trying to do photosynthesis
you're trying to take in carbon dioxide
from the atmosphere and you cannot help
but lose water in that process so in
order to keep on taking in carbon
dioxide through your stomata you need to
be able to replace the water you're
losing and if you cannot maintain that
steady state you have to close the
stomata and you have to stop water
synthesis so the ability to move water
very much matters for photosynthesis and
hydraulic capacity is can be very
strongly correlated with photosynthetic
capacity and hydraulic capacity of the
whole plant is very much tied up with
belief if we look at the resistance of
the entire pathway of water through the
plant at least half of it sometimes
two-thirds or more is tied up in the
last little bit that is represented by
the leaf you go up through the roots up
to Stan out the branch to the leaf that
was last little bit and even within
those centimetres the last couple
centimeters the reason there's so much
resistance in the leaf is actually tied
to the last couple microns right the
last millimeter or so which is the fact
that throughout that hydraulic pathway
water is moving through pipes designed
for water transport and it's when they
leave those pipes this is a cross
section of a leaf here when you leave
the the vasculature here to make it to
the stomata you're you're moving through
tissue that is not designed for a
hydraulic transport and much of the
resistance as a result is tied up in
that pathway through the mesophyll so
the hydraulic inductance of the entire
plant is very much tied to belief and
within the leaf it's really tied to this
path length from vane - stomata so
anything you can do to change that path
length is going to affect the hydraulic
capacity of the entire plant and the
easiest way to change that path length
is just to change the vane density if
you have more vanes those little blue
lines are going to be shorter the
maximum distance water has to travel
from the vein to the stomata is going to
be shorter and to demonstrate that this
really doesn't matter here this is
looking at the distance from vane to
stomata and the shorter of that distance
is the higher the leaf conductance to
water and the higher the leaf
conductance the higher the foods that a
great
you can do so this is all very much tied
to these vein characteristics so this is
looking at distance from vein two
stomata if you flip that around you get
vein density which is much easier term
to work with and that's just looking at
the millimeters of vein per square
millimeter of leaf surface there and so
if you look at that here this is vein
density versus maximum transpiration
rate and yes there's a very good
relationship here and now the fun thing
is that this is something that is
readily measurable in fossils we can
work with this trait and that becomes
very very important all right so here's
a living cycad living cycads are very
slow they grow very slowly but you would
never impune a Triassic cycad and say
that well they have to be growing slowly
like the living cycads for all we know
these guys have been displaced by the
spread of angiosperms maybe they were
more ecologically diverse in the distant
past before these transitions occurred
but no I can look at a variety of fossil
cycads they all look like the living
cycads
they're going to be stuck way down on
this spectrum here so we can it becomes
a very powerful tool for looking at the
physiology of fossil plants and
physiology through time and we looked at
a whole bunch of different plants and
first off don't worry about the colors
that had to do with a specific argument
about leaf development and how that
might be tied or not tied to two
potential vein densities the pattern to
look at here is the fact that these guys
down here which are the flowering plants
go way farther out on this axis than
anything else that has ever lived and
this includes a lot of exclusively
extinct lineages of seed plants and so
on as well as ferns up here as well now
perhaps the best way to look at this is
this graph here which is is being
density through time bein nestle is
incredibly stable in all non flowering
plants there's around to it you can go
down to about one millimeter of vein per
square millimeter of leaf surface it can
go up to around 5 but that's about it
until you get the evolution of flowering
plants where the average is about 8 to
10 and it can go up to 25 the lower
bound is still the lower bound but but
the mean and the maximum is about 4
times larger than any other group of
plants that has ever lived
and you can see what some of these guys
look like in practice here so this is a
fairly typical flowering plant that's a
fairly typical fern you can't even see
the smallest veins here whereas you're
seeing everything in that fern I had to
add this thing I gave a talk once and
there was a microbiologist who even
worked with leaves but yet and you've
seen these pictures of ferns that I was
putting up and he assumed that there was
more orders of veins that he couldn't
see they were there and that I was just
showing the bigger veins in them those
are all the veins there's nothing else
there and that really does is gonna end
up mattering physiologically I would
like to pause though and say that the
veins are not magic
right this is not a magic leaf if I took
one of these and stapled it to a psychic
you would not get a magic fast-growing
cycad you would get a dead leaf and this
is what this is doing is integrating a
lot of the biology the whole biology of
the organism it's just in a way that we
can actually been measuring fossils to
get an illustration of that kind of
integration I'm gonna do a bit of a
tangent that will actually come back and
be important later on where there's a
paper that I was not involved in I'm the
senior author here is a mushroom see in
this ski who's a close colleague of mine
and what they did is they made
artificial leaves out of gel and they
carved little channels in them ran a
tube to balance and they blew air over
the surface and evaporated water from
the surface as an artificial leaf and
what they were able to demonstrate is
that as you add more channels more veins
the amount of water you lose increases
but then it rapidly saturates and that's
that's where that saturation occurs is
going to reflect the thickness and what
they found was is that optimal placement
of these veins if you're trying to lose
water is when the distance between the
veins is the same as the distance from
that vein to the evaporative surface if
you have more veins than that it doesn't
matter if you're just going to flatline
and so this leads to expectations of
what leaves should look like in
cross-section these are all cartoons are
all cross-sections of leaves these are
good leaves these are what leaf should
look like if you have a very hot a lot
of veins and they're close together you
should this should be in a thin leaf
right
so that those bed D and the Delta are
the same if you have a thick leaf you
can have two different systems going on
if these are immediately placed then
then you said of a very low vein density
but you could also have these things
offset because what matters is not the
actual thickness of the leaf it's the
distance from the veins to the
evaporative surface with the stomata
these are good leaves these are bad
leaves that should not exist there is no
point to having a lot of veins if
they're far from that evaporator surface
because that evaporator surface can't
see them and it's just kind of wasteful
the construction and displace in the
photosynthetic tissue and so on
similarly this should be a problem
because the tissue immediately in
between these two veins should dry out
it shouldn't be getting enough water at
all and so you should actually be
actively killing stuff down in there so
we have expectations of what leaves
should look like and then they went out
and they measure a bunch of plants and
wow that's a that's a biological paper
and every and they get a relationship
that good so this is this is very
present this is the one to one line that
they wanted and everything is right
there on the one in one line from
Finley's down here to thick leaves up
there when I saw this when this came out
this was when I was first kind of
sitting down and measuring bein SAT a
lot and it's like all I was doing with
my time for a while there and this paper
immediately bothered me because it was a
big problem with this and what that
problem was was where the ferns ferns
have thin leaves and they have very low
vein densities so they should be
plotting out here not on that line and I
watching very well he's a very good
scientist I don't think he's screwed up
but I had a theory about what was going
on which was that the authors were all
either hydraulic physiologist or actual
physicists they were probably only
grabbed a bunch of plants during the
university campus they just grabbed
stuff and they and they measured it if
you do that and you're sampling this
kind of environment and what I suspected
was going on was that it was not just a
simple line that there was a slightly
more complicated relationship for these
different types of leaf types these are
the good leaves here on the line these
are the bad leaves I mentioned this bad
leaf should just never happen
I'm having to over-investing abeyance
there's no reason to ever do that so
that shouldn't exist but this could
exist as long as you live in a sheltered
environment so what I suspected one
this original paper and how they got
such a good relationship is they were
only sampling out here as far as degree
of exposure and all those things are
going to be one-to-one but if you got
things living the shade and wet
environments and so on they could fall
off that line and that that's where
you're gonna find the ferns so we went
and we sampled a whole bunch of stuff
and yeah that's what it looks like it's
not aligned since triangle now the first
thing to say about this is that is a
really glorious triangle right they
really did get the hydraulics right and
I had nothing to do with that I wasn't
on that first paper but they really did
get it right because there really is
nothing below that line the one to one
line really is what matters for this so
they I think that's a very good
indication that they really did do that
the hydraulics right they understand
what's going on but yeah we do fill in a
triangle here and knowing what all those
different symbols are there really is an
ecological gradient there where the
things in expose environments are on the
line and the things that fall off a line
are going to be much more sheltered
environments and there's even gradients
within look like within the ferns and
stuff like that so we saw what we
expected to see but we also saw
something that I didn't really
anticipate which is there's a big kind
of separation of different file o
genetic lineages as well so I already
mentioned the ferns and yes there's an
ecological gradient here where the ferns
down there are tree ferns and exposed
environments and so on versus guys are
in deeper shade and they all have been
leaves so they none of them can be very
good although there can be better or
worse gymnosperms also have low vein
densities but they can have thicker
leaves so they can end up actually kind
of grading onto this line by virtue of
having very thick leaves so they there
and again there is also this ecological
gradient and I'm not showing the data
but all the fossils we looked at are
actually consistent with that suggesting
that the ecology is that we're seeing
these living guys are consistent and
ferns have always been ferns and cycads
boys and cycads ecologically as far as
what they can do so we set up the system
where the canopy and and smaller trees
and more open environments are gonna
have these thicker leaves and on these
various images they're capable of doing
that whereas these guys can be more
restricted to be sheltered environments
but then all the angiosperms we looked
at violated that in a very interesting
way it doesn't matter where you are
ecologically at the angiosperms are on
the line deep shade angiosperms are also
on the line even though they don't have
to be which is very interesting to think
about their evolution
except that's derived angiosperms here
the red angiosperms
they look like the ferns so across the
of the basal angiosperms phylogeny they
start out all looking kind of very ferny
in these relationships and then once
they get on that line and more derived
angiosperms they stay there forever and
you can see that here this is plotting
it this is just looking at the ratio so
right so you don't know where you are on
this line but you know how far off the
line you are and this is everybody here
the furniture up here they're not so hot
the the various gymnosperms are slightly
better but not so much better and then
once all this is the angiosperms anita
basel guys this whole backbone is poorly
optimized but the core you dicots
and the drive monocots and specifically
the Loreal ease but the magnolias liz
Marelli's are better than the pipe
Raley's and so on and so the backbone of
this would have been very poorly
optimized and it's several independent
lineages within the flowering plants
that figured this out so there's been
there had been kind of a stable system
through time the the things that can
tolerate being open exposed environments
versus the things that couldn't but
could could handle this more sheltered
circumstances and then the angiosperms
came along and completely violated that
whereas these things would have their
thin leaves were incapable of a lot of
gas exchange but didn't necessarily have
a lot of need for that gas exchange
that's what I could handle having so few
vanes whereas these guys or much thicker
and are therefore capable of much less
gas exchange but they're the ones that
actually had the light and so on
what angiosperms did was they figured
out how to take leaves that should have
been in the shade and put them at the
top of the canopy and that's something
that basically only they have to
now which speaks of a lot of what
they're doing and how different it is
biologically and these aren't magic
these really are integrating an awful
lot about the over a while oh well I'll
do at the plant okay he's got two
different um the rest of this talk I'm
going to explore what that actually
means for the earth and for the plants
and the ecosystems and so on to start
out I'm going to talk about this climate
here so this is a graph I already showed
you how vein density scales to maximum
transpiration rates transpiration
matters particularly if you go to
tropical systems recycling of rainfall
and account for 30 to 50 percent of the
rainfall that falls on a rainforest it
falls out of the sky the plants suck it
up put it back up in the sky so it can
fall down again this is showing this
kind of cloud seeding over the forest in
the Amazon and president over the forest
not over the ocean in the same way so
that matters and I'm saying that those
transpiration capacities up here would
not have been present before the
evolution of flowering plants in the
same way so that the evolution of
flowering plants is relevant to thinking
about the evolution of tropical
rainforests now I'm not saying that
flowering plants invented rainforests
there will always be a tropical rainy
belt right here it is stretching across
the ocean that is not the distribution
of sea grasses there this always always
would have existed and similarly if you
have mountains near near coastline they
can squeeze water out of this guy so
there always would have been little
distributions of rain forests in fact
angiosperms had to have evolved in them
based upon the ecology of basal extant
lineages so they did have to pre exist
however transpiration is important to
these systems they may very well have
been important in kind of the spread of
these things depending upon how
important that is and the question
becomes well how important is it
so I engaged with a postdoc jungang Lee
who is a climate modeler and we look at
some of these things plants are part of
climate models as they exist and they
have physiological parameters in there
and what we ended up doing is we just
turn the one knob that had to do with
these physiological rates and looked at
what the outcome
these are standard models for atmosphere
notion using modern circumstances modern
condition surface temperatures all we
changed was the transpiration capacity
of the plants and it mattered I'm just
looking at the Amazon based on basin
here this is a difference map so it's
showing how much rainfall is lost in the
absence of flowering plants and we have
the same biomass of plants we just
changed the physiology of the plants to
a non angiosperm kind of mean average
value and at the center that bullseye
over losing about 1,500 millimeters of
rainfall per year which is a lot if we
look at that temporally rather than
spatially but this is still over the
Amazon basin there's a variety of
interesting things to see so the blue is
is present day and and the blue versus
the black shows how closely the the
model corresponds to actual values and
in the absence of the flowering plants
the basin is hotter and drier and it's
much more seasonal seasonally it's up to
5 degrees hotter because at the tail end
of that dry season transpiration becomes
very important for the latent the
sensible heat becomes very important for
for cooling off the forest and it gets
much much hotter once you turn off that
transpiration so we're hotter
we're drier and we're more seasonal in
the absence of flowering plants being
present in the system and overall the
area of what gets defined as ever what
rain forest based upon number of rainy
days per year drops by 80% there's still
a rain forest band but it much more
current is much more confined to where
the ITCZ that a tropical rainy belt
would be situated it's not that
massively expensive amazon basin that we
have now I'm showing you the Amazon
because that's where it works the best
you can see that here there are global
effects they are less severe in other
places and they are less severe for
fairly obvious reasons
Africa is high topographically and you
have the East African plateau which
constrains where you can get
precipitation from so it's hard to make
africa wet and Southeast Asia is a bunch
of mountainous Isle
in the tropics it's hard to make them
dry you can't make them dry
so there's reasons for for--why the
impact is less in other places but like
in Eastern North America it's still a
50% really reduction in in precipitation
is just a different color because
there's less overall it's still 50% of
what's going on and there's reason to
think that what's going on in the Amazon
basin I think is perhaps relevant to
some things that are going on in Earth
history
this is the Eocene here the dark
hatching is a distribution of tropical
aspect rainforests even though some of
these things are rather high latitudes I
think the fact that there was this kind
of extreme spread under these warm
circumstances in the Eocene made very
what well have been related to the
transpiration capacities of that
vegetation which was flowering plant
dominated and one way to think about
that is if we this was not the only time
the earth has been very warm if we go
back a little bit earlier hoops that's
the wrong way back to earlier in the
Cretaceous
it was also warm but what we're talking
about in North America and so on is
seasonal aridity and the difference is
turnover and what that vegetation is was
composed of what this forest canopies
would create it would've been much less
transpiration in this world in any case
if you just thought about the physical
nature of this world this should have
been the wetter world because this is
when we have lots of internal sea waves
breaking up these continents and the
pathway from moisture movement should
have been much less so just kind of
based up on those reasons this should be
wet and this should be dry but that's
the app opposite of what we actually see
so I think this could have been very
important earlier in Earth history
earlier in the history of angiosperms in
particular and it also sets up a very
interesting dynamic because plant
diversity itself is tied to
precipitation levels this is some work
of correction yes here or what they're
showing is that this is potential
evapotranspiration so this is kind of
how warm it is how much water you could
evaporate which is related to solar
influx and what it shows is that looking
at diversity and lots of localities
around the world and what it shows is
that if you're cold getting warmer
matters
right that's this area here but once
you're relatively warm getting warmer
still doesn't doesn't make a difference
what does make a difference is
precipitation so and and this is also
you know where angiosperms are the most
hyper diverse so they are creating the
very environments where much of their
diversity is situated they're
propagating them out much larger than
they otherwise would have been based
just on physical parameters and then
that does matter also for animal
diversity and everything else these are
looking at primate diversity and animal
diversity is also correlated with
rainfall abundance evenness and
rainforest area to the monkeys care that
is raining I don't think the monkeys
care but they put the plants care and
they care about the plants so
terrestrial diversity as a whole is
gonna be very much impacted by the
evolution of this physiology that is
unique to the flowering plants and I
think you can perhaps even see this in
other lineages of plants this is a fern
phylogeny where the green is evolution
of epiphytic ferns the lines there you
can read that at all but the lines here
represent the KT boundary which is the
end of the Mesozoic started the Cenozoic
flowering plants evolved around in here
and all these lineages of epiphytic
plants are evolving after this
transition to a flower and plant
dominated world these guys are the filmy
ferns they're they're kind of crazy but
I think there's plenty bit reasons to
ignore them but if you look her in Earth
history
where are the epiphytes so this is the
Triassic of Greenland it would have been
the warmest consistently what placed at
the time the tropics at that time were
more seasonally dry so this is as close
as you're gonna get to a rainforest type
situation there play these plants have
been reconstructed as Liana's or vines
but there's no epiphytes and i think
this may reflect this transition where
amplifies are going to be very dependent
upon the regularity of rainfall and that
regularity is going to be buffered by
the existence of flowering plants in
these in these later time periods
so I think their evolution has greatly
impacted climate in a way that then also
impacts just diversity of both the
plants themselves and and and everybody
else that goes along with them in these
ecosystems
that's climate this is also I think an
be very relevant for productivity now I
showed graphs that were just very kind
of clear-cut productivity should scale
at vane density it gets a lot more
complicated than that
and bear with me please because
productivity is also be dependent upon
other factors the most obvious of which
is going to be atmospheric co2 and that
has fluctuated quite a bit we're
actually now in a very low level of co2
versus the distant past and that initial
paper would on bein done see what there
was four of us we're all expatriates of
Missy Holbrooke slab we were all
postdocs at the same time there and two
of those authors were Tim broad ribbon
Taylor field and they worked went off
and measured a whole bunch of more
angiosperms more than I ever cared to do
because they're the hardest things to
measure and which was great but then
they also kind of developed a model over
how this relates to carbon dioxide
changes through time that I felt was
very problematic and what they argued
was that the effective main density is
going to saturate at high carbon dioxide
concentrations so that there's no
advantage for high vein density when co2
is high and it's only a co2 declined
from the Cretaceous to the present that
suddenly becomes in these high vein
density values become useful and that's
when these things are occurring so a
leak the evolution of angiosperms to
declines in co2 through time and they
talked about this in terms of a big
increase in photosynthetic potential I
was kind of concerned by this model
though because the back end of it is
problematic so what this graph here
shows and it was just kind of in the
supplementals was different crops versus
tropical trees versus non angiosperms
and what they do in the modern world and
there's these big differences between
them but sure everything saturates at
high co2 but they haven't saturating way
the heck of it here so what this is
saying is any crappy fern if you get
enough co2 it would be much more
productive than mazes
right now and that felt wrong and this
actually fits into a larger debate I
mean this is evolutionary biology and so
the debate happens at the rate of you
know paper every five years but a
variety of people have come out on
either side of this where there's a a
variety of people that are very kind of
invested in carbon dioxide through time
and wanting to make this as the driver
of much of what's going on in evolution
and this is the paper I was just talking
about bra driven field and then a
variety of these others as well a lot of
them led by David Bering and his
students so there's this focus on this
extrinsic driver of co2 in other cases
and not really kind of not always aware
of what they're arguing against I
certainly wasn't aware of it in some of
the cases I was arguing against this are
people that have focused much more on
the intrinsic biology of the plants
I think the best-known of these would be
bonds great paper about The Tortoise and
the hare
and the differences in the potential
ecology of angiosperms versus uh he was
largely talking about conifers but you
can expand it beyond there and so you
know the same co2 changes are occurring
but there's just no interest in
emphasizing that as far as what's
driving the changes in the ecology
through time and I thought that this
model might be an actual very
interesting way to test some of this
because the model they uses is
reasonable it's the same photosynthetic
models they've been used since the early
1980s
they've been very well vetted and so on
and but they found a way to include vein
density in it which is another way to
get at the fossil record and they
actually set up some very interesting
tests here they emphasize this flat line
and why there's no advantage to high of
aim density when co2 is high but they
didn't talk about which I find it much
more interesting is just how steep this
is because no plants ever no other
plants besides the angiosperms ever made
it up here but any plant can do this
within this pink range here and if this
is an extrinsic driver it should be
affecting all plants equally that's
what's inherent in this graph here and
how they have the ferns getting so
productive as well but what that means
is that if you're at this down at this
lower range of what other plants do any
incremental increase in your vein
density is good
huge difference in what you can do as a
plan in ways that should not matter for
the overall hydraulics of the plant but
what it just means is that when co2 is
that high and photosynthetic rates can
be that high if you're not doing it all
the time you're gonna get overgrown just
like that so there's a huge disadvantage
to having very low vein densities and
the expectation would be that the look
the upper bound maybe that just can't
change outside of the angiosperms but
the lower bound and everybody should
increase at times of high carbon dioxide
concentrations you should lose the lower
half of this pink range here and it just
doesn't happen so this is this is one of
burners models or this is co2 through
time showing the time periods that we we
looked at and we look at vane density at
these time periods and there's no change
there's no dependence upon the co2 what
that lower bound looks like the medians
in all these cases are basically down in
this zone where there should be nothing
at all and it's not really impacted and
I'm not showing the data but there's a
variety of co2 models and if you try the
different ones it's all the same you
know the location of these of these bars
will change up and down but but there's
always stuff up here and there's always
stuff down there and and there's no
effect on the vane density so this
didn't work so something's wrong with
that with that model and yet it's it's a
good model right so we got curious about
whether we could figure out you know
rather than just saying this is wrong
and walking away saying well what
happened and and can we improve upon it
so this is the model that they use the
way they incorporated vane density into
these photosynthetic models so they got
leaf conductance via the vane density as
pure as per those empirical graphs that
the Tim broader did himself so um so
that's how they got the leaf conductance
and then flow into the leaf is going to
be dependent on a leaf conductance and
the water potential gradient and then
the flow into the leaf has to balance
the evaporation from the leaf which is
gonna be related to the vapor pressure
deficits and stomata conductance so then
we can get stomata conductance from the
vane density and then that can be
plugged into a model of the physical
limits of diffusion on
co2 getting into the leaf and then that
can be solved simultaneously with a
different model of photosynthesis based
upon the biochemistry you saw those
simultaneously and that's how you end up
with with these curves here so is there
a way that we can kind of fix what they
did to actually get something that
worked with the fossil record the first
correction we did was getting back to
that thing I showed you about leaf
thickness because they used all these
being the same thickness
when actuality it should in some ways
correlate with the vein density that
they're showing it was very gratifying
we did that correction and so they had
some empirical data that they used to to
correlate there their graph and our
correction actually matches their data
better so that made us happy but then
when you look at the resulting curve it
doesn't really matter you still have a
big disadvantage to the lower end of the
vein densities that any plants can do
and this is showing the rate gained in
the simulation with vein density here
and you can see how much it matters it
if you can creep up out of this root
zone here as far as the overall
photosynthetic gain that would be
possible so that didn't help we tried a
variety of other Corrections they didn't
really play with oxygen whereas that's
going to affect for the respiration rate
and oxygen also has fluctuated through
time we played with stomata conductivity
which should go up and down with carbon
dioxide concentrations independently of
what's going on with the veins we tried
all those things and none of them matter
so none of these Corrections matter and
then they only looked at discretely like
low versus high co2 we look at it
continuously we're here the colors are
the assimilation rates but we look
continuously at all potential co2
concentrations and you just see how the
colors stack up here it doesn't matter
once once you have this low co2 regime
it matters immensely
getting a little bit higher in these
vain densities and they don't do it so
none of these corrections to what they
did make any difference whatsoever so we
have to look a little bit beyond that
and the one solution that does work is
if we just say maybe ferns can't be
sunflowers if we lower this VC max
maximum carboxylation rate and just
assign different rates to different
lineages it
she solves everything because what ended
up happening then is that you still have
a plateau related to vein density and at
different co2 concentrations but what
happens is the high co2 concentrations
that plateau occurs right at the base of
vein densities that plants do anyway so
basically ferns don't care about certain
co2 concentrations in that regard
higher co2 concentrations they're not
going to be any more productive is the
argument there and that it's really only
the angiosperms that are potentially
going up going up there now that goes in
the model as maximum carboxylation rate
but again this is something where it's
integrating the overall biology of the
plant carboxylation Rubisco that is very
co2 dependent sure and so and people
have always kind of assumed that it
should just track co2 but you also have
to the whole rest of the calvin cycle in
the regeneration of rubp
that is not co2 dependent and then
there's a variety of other things that
have to do with productivity like
phosphorus and nitrogen that use need if
you're going to be that much more
productive you need more phosphorus and
nitrogen and there's some indication
that that's actively kind of gets harder
su2 concentrations increase
alright the very least it's unrelated so
there's plenty of reasons to think that
you can't just amp up co2 and expect
everything to go along with it ok is
there other reasons to think that this
might be true if we take exit and plants
and these are all just numbers from the
literature and give them elevated co2
concentrations what happens yes if
flowering plants end up here ferns and
conifers that have been done don't so
this is consistent right and there's no
ferns out here potentially to go up
there as far as their vein densities and
yet you know what and within the range
that they do exist there doesn't appear
to be much of an impact of elevating
that carbon dioxide concentration people
haven't focused upon that because
they're more interest in these overall
patterns and the big things up there but
there's no reason to think that these
guys could have responded in that way
based upon this and it's even consistent
in a very fun way with the fossil record
so this is data from a follow-up paper
from these guys on Levi taylor field
where they measured a whole bunch of
cretaceous plants the black circles are
non angiosperms the white circles are
angiosperms
we look at the black circle if they say
what what I've been saying that there's
no response to whatever fluctuations of
co2 went on in this time period they're
just kind of merrily continuing on with
this flatline as far as their vein
densities early flowering plants
share that full range including the
lower half below that yellow line which
is corresponds to that that steep part
of the gradient there as they evolve the
high vein densities and presumably the
various physiological capacities that go
along with that they lose those those
main messages so they are responding the
way you might expect if this model was
correct but it's only the flowering
plants to do it so I think this is
potentially a very useful way to
actually bring the fossil record to bear
on some of these relationships that have
been proposed these are this is the
graph I've shown explicitly versus co2
concentrations these papers various
papers from David burling's work just is
relative to time and this is largely
tied to co2 fluctuations and I think
basically you can throw out the top half
of all these graphs they never got there
and I think there's even reasons to
think independent reasons that they
couldn't have ever gotten there which is
all of these graphs are ultimately
dependent upon the work of Bob burner
and his modeling of co2 concentrations
through time and burner is very explicit
about what goes into his model and
plants are a big part of it because the
primary draw down of co2 from the
atmosphere is via silicate weathering
and that's largely mediated by plants
all the acids pumped down into the soil
by roots and so on increases that so the
biggest feedback on co2 concentrations
are plants and the idea is that as you
have if you have more co2 if there's
more productivity and that leads to the
drawdown of more co2 and so co2 comes
back down and he tries he has these
sensitivity analyses looking at the
levels of carbon dioxide fertilization
and and it's right there in his papers
oh if you had as much co2 fertilization
as shows up in these grand graphs then
you wouldn't get any change in co2 at
all
because it would just be swamped out by
the plants immediately sucking up that
co2 and
with the silicate weathering ultimately
the silicate weathering of rocks on land
ends up in carbonate rocks in the oceans
and so there's definitely a co2
fertilization effect but if it was as
extreme as as these paper papers
rely they wouldn't get the co2 curve
that they're using to generate those
graphs in the first place so that big it
couldn't been that productive yeah it
just wouldn't worked out in that way so
I think productivity really has greatly
increased with the evolution of
flowering plants as well otherwise he
may be the baseline of these papers is
that we're actually living in a world
that is very deep operating and very
less lush than it used to be and that I
find that hard to believe right so that
that's just an internal bias on my part
but it doesn't feel right to think that
the most productive environments were
ferns in the Jurassic relatives what we
have now
so climates changed a lot productivity
has changed a lot and I think that as a
last step and this is just a couple
slides I promise it's been interesting
to use that to think back to the earlier
record and and as I said this is really
where what I like to think about the
most but this becomes very important
because paleo ecology has to be founded
on modern ecology and modern ecology is
flowering plants there's no place on
earth in the terrestrial environments
where flowering plants don't represent
at least 90 percent of the species even
if you go to Siberia most of the biomass
will be the same couple species of
conifers but most of the species are
gonna still be row basis plants
underneath that that are all flowering
plants so modern ecology is flowering
plant ecology but everything I'm saying
says that that probably is not a good
way of thinking about this system here
back in the Carboniferous and there's a
variety of the implications of that I'm
just going to kind of touch on a couple
but this is kind of the stuff that
interests me the most at this point
going forward one this sometimes gets
maligned by a call just now I don't I
don't know why I kind of like it it's
useful this is Grimes triangle looking
at ecology based upon kind of different
guilds of competitors your stately oak
trees and so on versus weeds
things that reproduce very quickly use a
lot of resources and then
reproduce and die versus stressed
tolerate errs they're slow growing and
also have a very low reproductive output
and this is related to intensity of
stress and disturbance and so on but two
of these three vertices here are
dependent upon high productivity so
basically I think that this is
angiosperms and in the world without
angiosperms you still have some
differentiation here but we're talking
about a much more limited triangle
basically I mentioned this to build a
michael who is a paleo ecologist and he
said and his immediate response is yeah
like I was on my high school football
team and if you know build a Michael
he's about that big and and not big in
any dimension but in a high school team
there's just less competition so
relative to the NFL so there's still
becoming differentiation within this
space because it's we much more limited
than what we see in the modern world
based upon the fact that we're much more
constructed constricted in this this
range of photosynthetic potential and I
think there's evidence that that is
gonna be present because I'm basically
I'm talking about world without weeds in
a very real sense and I think that that
may be correct right we have herbaceous
plants but we don't have annuals really
in the fossil record now in part that's
also can be tied to angiosperm
reproductive biology right so this isn't
the whole story but things like Bracken
is the one thing that gets often brought
up in this kind of context as being a
competitor it's slow growing it's not a
competitor by any kind of modern sense
it's just that it's hard for other once
it's there there's an incumbency effect
and things can't grow up through it but
it is definitely not a rule a weed and
it's not really a proper competitor by
it by these if by these modes and kind
of one last thing to think about in this
regard this is an over sampling of the
Westphalian be in the Carboniferous so
this is less than a million years this
is effectively one time slice I chose
this time slice one because we have a
lot of fossils from the Carboniferous
and also co2 concentrations were about
what they are now then so even if you
don't like what I said about carbon
dioxide photosynthesis would be tight of
a density then the way it is now because
it's the same
we have a lot of lady jizz here I've
sampled this about as well as we had in
that original paper sampled modern
plants so we know this as well as any
other time flies and these are all from
England right so this is all basically
one flora and there are some
differentiation there but there is all
incredibly low relative to what's seen
in living flowering plants everything
everything is maximally what you would
only expect to see in the deep shade if
we're talking in an angiosperm system
and they're largely even lower than that
kind of thing which I think it's kind of
fun to think about in terms of just the
original evolution of vascular flora
it's often kind of couched as kind of
reaching for the light as far as why we
evolved trees on so like that I only
mean these things cared about like I
don't think any of them were light
limited they had other things to worry
about and that no one would these none
of these plants were desperately wanting
the light levels that a modern
angiosperm tree wants and and yet that's
kind of often when we look at them and
this is a graph I put together myself
many years ago I'm so I'm as guilty of
it as anyone else but very often when we
think about kind of the Devonian
evolution the Paleozoic evolution of
vascular plants it's implicitly there
that were talking on ecological
succession and what goes on in
ecological succession but these guys are
all fighting over light in a way that I
don't think was going on here and it
gets into questions about why be a tree
at all then all right if you're not
trying to shade your neighbors and you
get to the light why are you doing this
and I think that there can be a variety
of kind of non-intuitive but interesting
things to explore in this regard of it
couldn't part be related to being
long-lived
because plants keep growing and and they
can't really avoid it
it can even be involved with things like
like rooting death instead where if
you're rhizomatous you're never gonna
get roots they're that deep with these
adventitious roots where there can be a
point to being a deep rooted plant but
that's something that only trees can do
so it could be as much about what
they're doing growing down
growing up one example of this that's
fairly local is bill Stein over at
Binghamton has has a locality where they
where they have these casts of the tree
stumps and there's one kind of basal
relative one of these guys here actually
although that actually might be a basal
see plant but a relative of the seed
plants growing rise ominously and it
goes from about here all the way across
that room that would been many many
years of growth and throughout that
growth if the thing is gonna stay alive
it has to keep growing but if your eyes
amitis growing horizontally you're
constantly changing your environment as
you go whereas there might be a point to
sitting in one spot if you need
long-lived and growing up and it also
allows you then to extract more
nutrients at depth and more water and so
on so it might be more complicated than
then the easy analogy that's available
from modern ecological succession and
basing things on light ok one conclusion
slide so why are plants are different
and they're different in ways
morphologically that translates to their
physiology and that because physiology
matters for climate and climate is
relevant to the fact that they're all so
hyper diverse and and and biodiversity
in these environments which they
dominate which is all environments
they're also more productive in a way
that I think is is not going to be
related to carbon dioxide the way it has
been often related in the older
literature in the current literature and
the fact that they're so different
it makes it problematic to easily kind
of translate from modern ecology to
paleo ecology what's going on there and
it's kind of a last point here I haven't
talked about flowers I've been talking
about flowering plants having talked
about flowers at all and very often when
people talk about flowering plant
evolution they're focusing on the
differences in the reproductive biology
and they certainly are extreme and they
matter a lot in a lot of ways both but
as far as their overall dominance of the
planet
I think the vegetative biology is as
relevant right because I'm sure if
you're gonna have two hundred fifty
thousand five hundred thousand species
whatever it is most of those have to be
rare right
and the reproductive biology of
angiosperms is very good at keeping rare
species sure that's great but they're
also most of the biomass and I think
that that really comes down to their
vegetative biology the the reproductive
biology allows them to subdivide all
that real estate very finely but the
reason they have all that real estate in
the first place I think is income much
more down to their vegetative biology
that's at least as important when
thinking about the role of angiosperms
in the modern world and how they evolved
okay thank you this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at cornell edu